I just want to show you lastly here we
go how to make sure you can find how to
make sure you can find each of these
understandably fought because so far I
think you've mostly been seeing it give
it two in a table or in a list but
you've got to be careful with Donna like
this you've got to make sure you read it
properly okay so we'll do them one at a
time how do you find the mean here are
all your scores now that you can
actually read them how are we going to
find them in here what kind of
information you look on the side um what
information I gonna need okay good so
I'm going to need to add up some school
let's do them with me right what are the
scores aren't adding up this is the moon
that we calculate in there 51 52 etc
okay let's get them all down 51 50 to 60
62 65 okay good someone can be adding
these up by the way don't forget this go
happens twice so you include it twice
right 75 and 75 what's next 86 87 and
okay cool so you're going to get a
number and all that okay so you've done
both having you you've added them up and
then what did you / 12 okay good so you
counted out there are 12 scores and that
gives you can you repeat the number
again 79 15 yeah that's cool all right
does it seem like a reasonable
description of the center of this group
yeah i think so i think it does and
you'll notice the reason why you can
because look at it sideways this is a
pretty normal sort of set of data right
it's not like it's skee ball boiler yoga
so that's all right the mode that's
pretty actually no more up to a million
sorry the median that is two ways to do
this okay we'll find out whether it's 71
in a second what's what's a quick way
that I could find out where the middle
score is yeah
okay good so I could I could cross off
score so I can go there's one bottom and
what a top bottom what you don't do us
any water okay sure you guys anything or
don't like what if you put 70 you start
from the final morning ah so I'm so glad
you asked that remember i showed you
this before right let's put some more
scores on the NCR okay you kind of dizzy
you kind of have to count from both
directions right because you want to
make sure you meet in the middle so
you'd say one at the bottom one at the
top one bottom one at the top and then
you that I've got two left in the middle
and that's why we took the average okay
so you can see I'm counting both ways
cutting both ways sir so far I went 123
from the bottom this is the smallest
number I went 123 from top is the
biggest numbers let's keep going bottom
top this is counting down I bottom top
like I have a look okay so it's going to
be between 71 and 74 so the median is
okay now I'll just point out this was
kind of reasonable like this whole
crossing off thing there are other 12
scores right how would we do if there
are like 120 scores this would be
forever okay is there a quicker way that
doesn't require me to cross everything
off
what if I heard there is right he is the
idea of the middle I said it was like
sort of okay as a definition this is
better but if I told you how many scores
they were for instance if I said there
are a hundred scores you can tell me
whether little bit country which score
should it be yeah I need to say well
it's going to be around the 50th right
it's going to be around the 15 now to
know exactly let's think about a simple
one so if I have one two three four and
five you guys can all tell me it's silly
which one the central one is right the
median it's clearly going to be three
okay what if I said I money aspect
123456789 again instantly you can tell
me it's fine right so how can we rather
than just counting and looking at it how
can we go straight to three or five so
you just like just like / choosing in
the position of the number yeah very
good no what I point out it's a bit
unusual right here's a bit of a tricky
you may want to drop this down where
you've got comedian written down i'll
get to recover the shortcut rather than
counting your way there right which is
quite inefficient the shortcut is to say
if you've got n terms like like five
terms or so scores or nine scores right
what you say is with that number in you
add one and you divide that by two what
how it works you've got five scores here
so I'm going to add one which gives me
six and then divide by two excuse me oh
how about this one the number of course
is 9 so I'm going to add one which gives
me 10 and i divided by two which is me
five that's a that's a good question
both of these you've noticed are odd
numbers right so there's a middle but
this one how many scores are Bentley
there are six scores so if I did this
process again right if i took that now
but added one and divided by 2 this is 3
a half what does that mean
it's between the third and fourth terms
you can have to take the average right
does that make sense so this is a much
quicker way of doing things and that's
why you should write it in from a big
box around because if you have any
decent sized set of scores then can t go
to take you forever okay find out how
many terms there are you need to know
that I like your average or what have
you add 1 and then advise the whole
numbers by two and then Tyler anyway
yeah it works all the time or when you
on the median directly or it will tell
you you should be halfway between this
one in that one okay I came to finish
modes easiest what's the mascot let's go
75 okay fantastic so you can see it's
the only one the tumbles up I will point
out and you maybe want to write this
underneath where you've said mode it's
the only one out of these three measures
that you can have multiple ones right if
for instance I was the hijacker data and
put in another 52 there's no reason why
you can't save 75 and 52 they're both
the mode I recalled by middle and I
could say I could put in another one no
mother 6552 and 65 and 75 they're
already removed okay so if for instance
everyone in the class going different
score on your doom then everyone's mark
would be the moon it's not very useful
in that case